um let's just look at what you're doing
with these knife strips okay uh you're
basically leveraging it out you see that
so here you have just a lever so stay
there you didn't have to stay exactly
like that okay all right all right so
it's just a lever which is like think of
it as a as a rigid stick okay a rigid
line all right and uh there's weak
points in the grip the pinky and the
thumb okay so every time you can always
pry these out you see how it's prying on
your pinky so the fulcrum is going to be
on the other side of your hand that's
and that lever is pressing on that part
there where I'm touching okay and then
I'm using the length of the lever to pry
out the pinky so as you close your
fingers I just pry that out you see that
and you can go either way so I'll use
this side now of your hand this part
where the stick is touching your hand
and I can now pry out that lever out the
thumb do you got it okay so if your
fulcra moves you will have less Force as
you're using the same lever so see how
keep it your hand still okay if you turn
your hand you'll see that it's not going
to work until now your joints have taken
out the ability for your hand to rotate
and now I get that fulum again and now
it'll come out okay and following the
lever
laws if you have a shorter lever there's
going to be less Force I can generate in
the prime it's not that it can't be done
but it's nowhere near
having a longer lever okay you do you
guys see that okay so a lot you have to
understand these these principles try to
keep the fulcrum still don't let it move
and try to use the length of the lever
as much as possible okay now to show how
important
the uh stabilization of the fulcrum is
you can see that as I lock your as you
turn your hand and it's not till the
joints no longer articulate that the
fulcrum activates right okay but if you
move your body around you can see I
would follow the path yeah follow the
path you see and then it might not ever
come out do you see so if you bent
backwards you keep your grip on there
and keep the fulcrum the entire time you
see that so so you feel that will do it
again so I'm coming around and you keep
your grip you see I won't be able to get
it out till again I reached the limit of
those joints which is here and now it
could come out okay all right so we'll
have you guys just play with the stick
right now with those principles okay TR
all right so something to uh notice on
the stick to get those fulcrums to
work as uh as taking advantage of the
weak points of the grip you're always at
a right angle to the grip so if I take
this like this and I try to go this way
hold your grip ah it's going to take
longer before I pry that out okay same
thing here takes longer but so you're
always going to the right angle always
to the right angle always to the right
angle that's important so you get these
angles takes a lot longer you see how
much the lever is moving before I can
pry out even with the stabilized fulcrum
by holding her wrist you go here it
takes a lot longer takes a lot longer
before I can pry out okay so that's
important all right so when we go to the
knife and this thing's coming in uh
you're you're over here
right you're going to yield and as
you're going to field as this is going
around look how I got the right angle
here okay and so camera move around so
you can see that okay so we were
here and as I start to turn I rotate
around this cross
I now establish the cross on the knife
and I'm at that right angle okay and
then you use your deviation and
everything to obey the yinong rules and
eventually you'll slide down to here
okay and you keep that right angle on
there and as you move this around into
sh you're going to see that there's that
Prim angle you see it I don't have to do
anything anything I'm at the right angle
so camera moves around
wherever and in the movement alone of sh
Naga cuz I'm going to I'm going to turn
the wrist my hand is basically pushing
it out the same
way so move wherever you need to so you
can see this and we'll go slow so I'm
here I start to move and I'm going to
come around and get that right angle on
the forearm and you're going to feel it
and you're going to want to actually
feel it and this is why I started out
with the stick cuz everyone's fine
feeling the stick but you feel the knife
and you
go but the cutting portion is all your
concern and more importantly the drawing
of the cutting portion okay so even the
cutting portion not dry is not going to
bite you like you think it is okay but
when you're definely here this is you
want to feel that I want to feel that
cuz I know now you can't tatch me okay
and I come
around in the technique you'll work your
way down to the wrist and now in the
movement alone of shon nag you're going
to use that right angle to pry that
thing out so that knife should pry out
boom right at the center line of your
body
okay in this technique you you can do
this stuff right you're over here you'll
do like a version and it'll pry out over
there okay but in this technique I want
you to make sure that you're not prying
it
here okay
nor after over
here it should pry out at the hands in
the gon position now wom wom right there
PES out without any flipping of your
forearm do you guys see that so again
boom boom no Prime how it
goes we'll do it several times and you
move to where you see we'll slow down
boom that's what I want oh D I know I'm
safe now okay boom boom how it
goes
boom
well that
one I wasn't as right angle as I needed
to
be
okay let's try